avec une inflation proche de 5% notre
pouvoir d'achat devrait connaître cette
année un choc historique bonjour patrick
bonjour david patrick artus chef
économiste de natixis avec 5%
d'inflation c'est un truc qu'on n'a pas
connue depuis coin 40 ans oui peut-être
pas 40 ans les palois oui on a eu on a
connu ça dans les années 80 et puis très
transitoirement
certain moment sorti de la sortie de
récession dans le passé n'oubliez pas
que si l'état français n'avait pas pris
à sa charge une partie très importante
de la hausse des prix sera la première à
beaucoup plus de surface on serait pas à
ça qu'on serait à sept ou huit les
allemands sont à s'être l'europe et à
cet ennemi donc en fait moralement on
est à 7 on est à 5 simplement parce que
l'état a pris une partie de la facture
énergétique donc la contraction notre
point d'achat cette année sera très
importante et je crois qu'il faut
réfléchir au delà de cette année il faut
se dire alors cette année oui les
salaires vont augmenter de 3 % en bleu
mandat près toutes les informations que
nous avons des différentes branches
voire une inflation à 5 donc on aura
deux points de baisse du pouvoir d'achat
d'ailleurs on voit que pour l'instant
seul le pouvoir d'achat des plus
modestes pour l'instant résiste parce
qu'il ya encore des effets des chèques
énergie d'échec inflation
il faut quand même se placer dans une
perspective un peu plus longue pour
comprendre ce phénomène on retrouve un
monde où il ya des raretés on avait
oublié qu'ils avaient des raretés
aujourd'hui on a rareté de l'est de
l'énergie rareté des métaux rareté de
certaines matières premières agricoles
rareté du transport rareté des semi
conducteurs dans un monde où il ya plein
de rareté les prix montent et on a
oublié les mécanismes d'indexation des
salaires qu'on avait il ya 30 ou 40 ans
donc on a ce mélange rareté est faible
indexation des salaires mécaniquement
fabrique le recul du pouvoir d'achat et
je crois qu'il va falloir apprendre à
vivre parce que c'est rare t on les voit
pas disparaître de sitôt c'est quoi
c'est une très forte demande croissante
de biens l'électronique l'équipement de
la maison et ça c'est une conséquence de
la coville la russie c'est pas demain
que les sanctions sur la russie sont
enlevés et puis après la transition
énergétique qui va faire consommer
beaucoup de métaux qui va qui avait de
la tension sur les marchés de l'énergie
donc on va devoir apprendre à vivre
durablement avec avec d'inflation
beaucoup plus forte que que dans la
décennie 2010 alors ça ça pose plusieurs
questions la première c qui prend la
facture et là il ya une question
centrale qui est d'abord un combien de
temps l'état peut continuer à amortir le
choc à partir du moment où l'état ne
peut plus assurer cette charge
comment cette charge répartie entre les
salariés et les entreprises et ça c'est
crucialement la question de l'indexation
des salaires dans les années 80 les
salaires étaient très bien avec ses sur
les prix et donc les salariés étaient
protégés et la facture été prises par
les entreprises et on a eu un
effondrement des profits d'ailleurs dans
les années 80 et est en conséquence de
l'investissement est aujourd'hui pour
l'instant les salaires sont très malades
etc c'est donc les profits seront
présents que déjà le sujet il est là il
faut augmenter les salaires peut-être
pas tous en tout cas les bas salaires si
l'état accepté de pinces et des marges
des entreprises alors c'est globalement
globalement en bonne santé oui mais
c'est un débat assez profond elle est
essayé c'est vrai c'est vraiment le vrai
débat de politique économique qu'on
devrait avoir et qu'on n'a pas eue c'est
de dire si on a un horizon de temps
assez court on a envie de protéger la
consommation des ménages donc on va
privilégier une bonne indexation des
salaires sur les prix et sur nos
horizons dans l'eau on a envie de
protéger la croissance de long terme
donc de protéger l'investissement et
selon l'ord a plutôt envie de protéger
les marges donc c'est un vrai choix même
de prédire de société et à savoir si on
protège les salariés ou si on protège
les les marges des entreprises qu'il
faut expliqué patrick artus et que
autant en 2022 notre point d'achat va en
moyenne reculé autant depuis cinq ans
oui chiffres à l'appui linsellois wsop
thème les vôtres en moyenne le faire
d'achats a progressé pourtant les
français sont convaincus du contraire
est ce que le terme est traîné pas
casser écouter le client je crois pas
j'ai vraiment travaillé cette question
il ya le travail de l'eau est cela qui
qui qui qui vient d'être publiée qui
extrêmement intéressant qui montre que
depuis cinq ans jusqu'au début de cette
année puisque la de ces mois ci c'est
bizarre mais depuis cinq ans le pouvoir
d'achat de tous les français quel que
soit le niveau de revenu a progressé
d'autant plus que leur revenu est faible
donc non seulement à une progression du
pouvoir d'achat mais il ya eu leur
élégance et leur écrasante majorité le
contraire après les français en
attendant les enquêtes 80 % des français
disent qu'il ya un recul de leur pouvoir
d'achat alors l'explication usuels c'est
les fameuses dépenses contraintes ce en
disant oui
mais lille a beau nier
internet
l'énergie est bien sûr l'alimentation
ce n'est pas vrai non plus même si on
corrige des dépenses contraintes il ya
toujours une progression du pouvoir
d'achat des français même un petit peu
plus forte alors que si la différence
assez sur une perception c'est une c'est
une perception c'est sans doute que la
perception de ce qui est une
consommation indispensable quentin du
mal à boucler les fins de mois on a du
mal oui mais parce que oui mais parce
que c'est mon explication c'est que ce
qui est perçu comme étant indispensables
comme consommation est de plus en plus
large aujourd'hui personne n'imagine
plus de parloirs d'abonnement à des
plates formes de cinéma
il ya dix ans personne n'imaginait que
ça faisait partie de la consommation à
distance une dépense contrainte c'est à
dire en gros un certain moment
pratiquement tout devient une dépense
contrainte elle aussi tout études
dépenses contraintes évidemment il ya
des problèmes de pouvoir d'achat et il
faut l'accepter cirque il faut que les
politiques acceptent l'idée que quels
que soient les chiffres de l'insee qui
disent linverse les français ont la
perception que leur pouvoir d'achat
s'est réduit ce n'est pas vrai mais ils
ont cette perception donc on ne peut pas
faire comme si cette perception
n'existait pas et donc il va falloir
trouver des politiques de pouvoir
d'achat alors même qu a priori il n'y a
pas de problème qu'en tant que c'est une
situation qui est extrêmement complexe
et c'est une spécificité française à
vous avez pas ça du tout dans les autres
pays européens et donc comment trouves
comment on trouve une solution pour
faire changer cet état d'esprit des
français ça alors là les solutions elles
sont sur la table oro il faut s'attaquer
aux plus bas salaires donc augmenter bas
salaires augmentent et les plus bas
salaires mais ça va très vite à vous
savez on dit en général que les français
se sentent un peu à l'aise à partir de
2000 euros net par mois mais il ya 65 %
des français qui gagnent moins de 2000
euros d'être par boire donc ton combat
et est en ce moment en particulier le
smic augmente extrêmement vite puisque
lui il est indexé sur les prix mais pas
le reste des padres et donc on est en
train de casser encore plus la
hiérarchie des salaires au bas de
l'échelle des salaires dont deux
solutions
d'abord le smic et rappelez-vous que le
smic est indexé par sur l'indicé général
des prix mais sur un indice des prix
particulier aux français à revenus
modestes et puis deuxième solution ce
que propose beaucoup de patrons le medef
c'est
le dividende salarial c'est rigolo si
c'est très simple c'est une entreprise
qui ne verse pas d' intéressement une
participation n'a pas le droit de verser
des dividendes à ses actionnaires donc
c'est simple c'est si vous voulez verser
des dividendes aux actionnaires vous
devez intéressez vous avez vos salariés
aux résultats de l'entreprise c'est une
idée que le medef maintenant signe donc
c'est quand même assez intéressant de
voir cette évolution et puis voilà il
donc il faut faire des petites choses
comme ça mais si on perd on n'est pas en
position c'est pas les états unis on
peut pas augmenter tous les salaires de
10% parce que ça n'a aucune
justification macroéconomique on est on
est fondre aurait les marges
bénéficiaires des entreprises sachant
que les vraies inégalités patrick elles
sont peut-être même plus patrimoniale
nous ignorons dit pas assez on a des
chiffres dire là dessus oui on a des
chiffres parce que maintenant on publie
alors au d'abord on sait que les
inégalités de revenus en france c'est
con à mesure par la vieillesse de gym où
les inégalités sont nettement plus basse
que dans les autres pays européens dans
les eaux de la série street à faire aux
disparitions sera-ce la distribution est
à vendre distribution on est très
inégalitaire c'est peut-être d'ailleurs
ça j'aurais dû le dire avant une des
raison d'une dose explication c'est que
l'on est dans une situation où ce sont
les politiques redistributives qui
aboutissait des inégalités faible est-ce
que de l'argent reçu de l'état la prime
d'activité par exemple c'est perçu comme
de la même manière qu'un salaire c'est
pas tout à fait certain que c'est à la
même perception qu'un salaire d'un
garçon qui est versée par l'état donc
voila et puis de temps qu'il faut
effectivement trouvé des bois your aussi
de réduire les inégalités patrimoniales
alors qu' elle augmente considérablement
parce que les prix des actifs augmente
considérablement et que les plus on est
âgé plus on investit dans des actifs
financiers qui ont des rentabilités
élevées donc ça conduit à ce que les
salariés soient actionnaires de leur
entreprise alors il faudrait c'est alors
une des propositions c'est une
augmentation extrêmement forte de 2 des
distributions d'actions gratuites s'agit
pas de faire acheter des actions aux
salariés même avec un bonus un comme
c'est très fréquemment le cas j'ai donné
une partie du capital de l'entreprise
progressivement à ses salariés
aujourd'hui le cac 40 à 3 et demi pour
cent de son capital qui est propriété
des salariés des entreprises pourrait
dire président de la république pourrait
dire au terme du quinquennat sera 10%
pareil donc on aura enrichi patrimoniale
mans les salariés dans leur entreprise
il faut trouver des initiatives aussi
pour le polar les inégalités
patrimoniales un petit mot comme des
chèques énergie qui ont été distribués
par les pouvoirs publics est pour moi
une question ciblage on a donné 100
euros à 38 millions de français ce qu'il
fallait pas donner 400 euros à 9
millions de français oui et on aurait pu
parler aussi du de la remise de 18 cents
à la pompe oui c'est fini en bénéficier
à la fois comment dire aux hauts-sarts
et modeste qui prennent leur voiture
pour aller au boulot comme le cadre
supérieur qui prend soin suivait pour
partir en week-end à la campagne les 18
centimes d'essence ses bénéficiaires
tout le monde donc l'arbre de
déperdition d'argent public que
conseillera donc il faut pas faire ça et
en plus on fait disparaître le signal
prix ont fait semblant que l'énergie
fossile et pas cher que ce qui était
aberrant donc il faut laisser monter le
prix des énergies fossiles et il faut
faire des chèques aux plus modestes ça
coûtera beaucoup moins cher à l'état et
sa puce sera tout le monde à faire des
économies avec une inflation fini à ce
qui est structurellement plus élevée
dans les prochaines années notre point
d'achat sera sous pression quand les
taux d'intérêt les taux d'intérêt vont
continuer à monter on est ravis recul 4
% pour le taux d'intérêt à 10 ans à la
fin de cette année on sera peut-être à
2% la fin de l'année prochaine on sera
peut-être à 3% un certain moment l'état
ne pourra plus suivre et donc il devra
laisser les salariés les entreprises
s'expliquer entre eux et c'est là qu'on
aura à la
répartition pour l'instant ce mode de
répartition a été entièrement caché un
par les interventions de l'état merci
beaucoup explications signé patrick
artus donc chef économiste de natixis
merci patrick mercier dhabi
[Musique]